[Música]
luego de tres años de mandato las
encuestas apuntan a que el presidente
del salvador un equipo que le
cuestionado fuertemente por actores
nacionales e internacionales por algunas
de sus decisiones se mantiene su
popularidad al menos con un 90 por
ciento con los ciudadanos al mostrar
altos niveles de aprobación las dos
apuestas más fuertes de bukele en este
tercer año en el poder que ha sido
gobernado sin oposición en el congreso y
sin contrapeso en la corte suprema de
justicia fueron la opción del bitcoin
como moneda de curso legal vigente y la
llamada guerra contra las pandillas
dicha guerra se enmarca en un régimen de
excepción aprobada a finales de marzo
por 30 días y que ya fue extendido por
el parlamento dos veces por igual
período en materia de derechos humanos
las organizaciones sociales han señalado
que existe una violación sistemática
bajo el régimen de excepción
principalmente contra hombres jóvenes de
zonas empobrecidas y también acechadas
por las maras para ello entonces quiero
saludar a nuestro segundo invitado del
día el stithian o breda analista para
centroamérica del international crisis
group
gracias tiziano por estar con nosotros
en directo
france24 por supuesto un primer balance
de lo que son estos tres años de
gobierno de la l
muchas gracias por la invitación al
árbol y muy buenos días efectivamente yo
creo que el resultado que ya es más
extraordinario que ha tenido el
presidente bucl especialmente lo que
mencionaba la popularidad que ha sabido
mantener tres años después sin decaer
básicamente como es natural que tenga un
desgaste en cambio él ha sabido
con una estrategia comunicacional y una
maquinaria comunicacional
muy muy buena y claramente dos de estos
tres años han sido marcados por una
asamblea legislativa que todavía estaba
básicamente controlada por los partidos
de oposición entonces alimentó un poco
el el discurso popular populista y
victimista de bukele no totalmente
descabellado pero digamos que hay yo
creo que se dio un
giro muy fuerte en la segunda parte
cuando en el último año cuando
controlando la asamblea con dos tercios
de los votos hemos visto una aceleración
de ciertos rasgos
se podrían llamar los autoritarios del
presidente de hacer la concentración de
poder que efectivamente han estado
preocupando cada vez más sobre todo la
comunidad internacional porque al final
de cuentas internamente
digamos es un presidente que sabe muy
bien lo que necesita la población
salvadoreña ha hecho cosas que
efectivamente nunca se habían hecho
antes como dar subsidios monetarios
durante la pandemia entregas de comidas
o sea ayudas concretas a la población
y esto la población pues no lo reconoce
se lo agradecen claramente los
resultados en seguridad también han sido
parte de esta popularidad aunque sabemos
ahora cada vez más que este descenso en
los homicidios que ha conocido esa valor
pues se debió más bien a un proceso de
conversaciones entre el gobierno y las
principales pandillas más que digamos
con tener una recuperación de control
territorial que era lo que pretendía
proponer el gobierno a eso quería ir
tiziano si es verdad que el gobierno
tenía este pacto con las pandillas y que
habría pasado entonces con este pacto
que desató la criminalidad y estos
asesinatos en el salvador que realmente
está pasando allí y porque bukele
tampoco se ha referido digamos
explícitamente al respecto
pues no se ha referido porque el tema de
conversar o negociar llamemos como se
quiera con pandillas es un tema muy
impopular casi un tabú en el salvador a
pesar de que todas las administraciones
en los últimos 15 años y básicamente
casi todas las alcaldías también los
gobiernos locales han tenido que
interactuar con estos grupos por la
presencia por el poder que han tenido y
que tienen a lo largo y ancho del país
digamos reconocer que se pueda con
digamos identificarlos como
interlocutores es algo muy impopular y
por eso que digamos este gobierno
siempre ha negado que existieran estas
conversaciones y cuando salieron audios
incluso de un oficial de gobierno
admitiendo que había este proceso en
acto no se refirió al tema esto para mí
es porque si digamos el presidente no
para no hablar del tema
una buena parte de la población no sabe
de que esto está pasando
muchos no tienen twitter no leen el faro
en el presente porque es la diferencia o
entre las referencias de las digamos
fuentes de información
efectivamente no sabemos no todas las
piezas que hay en el rompecabezas en
este momento de lo que ha pasado
exactamente y para dónde vamos
parece que hubo una digamos unos roces
internos dentro del gobierno entre los
que querían mantener este proceso y
gente que en cambio quería interrumpirlo
hasta el momento las pandillas están
reagrupando se vemos una violencia muy
baja y todos están buscando como no ser
detenidos entre los 35 mil que se han
detenido en los últimos dos meses pero
esta política de estado decepción es
pero creemos nosotros insostenible en el
mediano y largo plazo y puede que cause
problemas el futuro claro también ha
sido muy criticada por organizaciones de
derechos humanos dentro y fuera del
saber precisamente por eso por denuncias
de detenciones arbitrarias denuncia
también de violaciones de derechos
humanos pero no quiero terminar nuestra
conversación sin hablar también de algo
muy importante y que ha sido estos tres
años de gobierno y la materia económica
no el uso del beat coin como una moneda
de curso legal vigente que tan
beneficiosa que tiene efectiva ha sido
esta reglamentación del bitcoin en la
que origina economía del salvador
yo creo que efectivamente el bitcoin
podría ser quizás el desacierto mayor de
este gobierno en el sentido de que
quizás nace la idea con un propósito
incluso bueno de inclusión financiera
para toda aquella población que no tiene
acceso al sistema bancario
y enrique que paga un montón de
comisiones para recibir las remesas de
sus familiares que están en otros países
pero la manera en que se llevó a cabo la
manera en que se implementó hoy muy
digamos discutible ya que la aplicación
que el gobierno impulso sea masivo bolet
fue bastante desastrosa en su
implementación en su funcionamiento y no
dejado como digamos la práctica no nos
dejó instalada no la práctica de usar
bitcoin como quizás pensaban el gobierno
además claramente ha creado mucha
incertidumbre a nivel internacional en
instituciones financieras como el fondo
monetario internacional con la cual el
gobierno estaba negociando un préstamo
de 13
de dólares
y esto complica el acceso a recursos que
el gobierno pueda tener y que necesita
porque tiene unos 800 millones de
dólares pendientes de deuda de pagar
desde externa en el próximo enero por lo
tanto yo creo que ha sido y además
claramente el valor de bitcoin que tan
volátil y que últimamente se han
desplomado
quizás pueda haber complicado aún más la
inversión misma que el gobierno ha hecho
en este tipo de script o moneda por lo
tanto efectivamente no sabemos aún por
dónde va pero podría ser esta quizás la
el desacierto tampoco la
la debilidad así que si queremos
llamarla de un gobierno que quizás no
tendrá suficientes recursos para seguir
adelante en los próximos años